parce que la semaine dernière je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez j'avais testé
votre notoriété auprès des seniors oui
ça avait donné des résultats un peu
particulier bon pour être équitable
cette semaine je me suis dit que
j'allais questionner des enfants change
en un pôle édition là j'ai pas demandé
de choisir entre deux chroniqueurs je
leur ai expliqué qu'à la télé en ce qui
ce qui est important c'était l'image
fallait être sympathique et rassurant
donc je leur ai montré vos photos je
leur ai posé deux questions 1
est ce que vous connaissez cette
personne et 2 est-ce que vous
accepteriez qu'elle soit votre baby
sitter ar vous sentez comment ça c'est
des photos officielles on n'est pas bien
là
allez on regarde le focus group
jean luc lemoine au sein croyable est ce
que tu te moques crée pas un peu de moi
quoi je vais vous montrer des photos de
gens qui passent à la télévision la
première question je vous poserai c est
ce que vous connaissez ces personnes est
la deuxième question c'est si il devait
de votre baby sitter accepteriez vous
est ce que vous connaissez cette
personne cyril hanouna
sachez que c'est un petit copain ouais
il s'appelle cyril lignac cyril lignac
exactement les scieries binya qui fait
quoi dans la vie et qui fuit et cuisine
donc l'idée pour lui quand il veut quand
il le veut c'est à dire il joue la
comédie en fait autant il a la tête de
rigolo qu'on voit par exemple est ce que
vous vous sentirez rassurer si c'était
votre baby sitter n'ont absolument pas
rassuré quand mes cd avec moi dans la
même pièce des jambes
elle a même re déjà je pense pas que mes
parents serait tout à fait d'accord sur
sa torpeur tu fasse des bêtises mais
j'espère qu'ils mettent fin à ma maison
je suis d'accord allez hop à saulxures
est ce que vous connaissez cette
personne ment pas c'est vous c'est moi
oui ça c'est le coup dur c'est ce qui me
fait de la peine c'est qu'au départ
vous avez dit c'est moi et maintenant
vous dites qui est moche il s'appelle
jean le champ de la fontaine
non c'était pas lui est en tout cas ça
veut dire que si vous l'avez jamais vu
soit il n'est jamais passé à l'antenne
soit il à 0 charisme
vous savez ce que c'est le charisme
c'est quoi la carrière qu'est ce que
j'en pense de moi moi je pense qu'il est
mais il marche ascensionnelle match
il vous propose jean michel maire de
huit sites en vous acceptez ou pas
pourquoi arthur paillasson et elle son
travail à faire des clients suivants
[Applaudissements]
merial watts on aurait donc à l'en avant
guingamp pee wee avec ses dents canine
on dirait un vampire ils sont sont
emmenés son visage on dirait un sorcier
je l'avais jamais vu je préciser des
choses quand même parce que là vous
allez finir par le vexer c'est pas alors
il est très beau c'est pas un vin très
confiant ce qui s'appelle gilles gilles
verdez connais pas je pense que j'ai
déjà la réponse que nous votre réaction
on n'était même pas en rêve
pourquoi et oui ça me prend du tout bon
sens moi je le jure
là